weighing up the mood of conservative
america
in a gun show in west virginia among the
rifle racks and ammunition
there's anger and dark talk of looming
conflict
i'm very worried about this country
where it's going if it keeps heading
down the same way
they're going to push people into
another civil war
he's not the only one robert brown sells
vintage guns from the 19th century
and says he also worries its civil war
could be on the way back
it could get worse and it seemed like
every day it does get worse
that's not good for us and if it gets
worse what kind of things can we see do
you think
uh not short of civil war
people that's not going to stand for a
lot of that stuff it's going to be
it you get your back on the wall you got
to come off of it
you think there could be another civil
war a possibility
a possibility seriously unfortunately
a lot of talk of it we found a lone
democrat at the show
here to buy ammunition he said in case
things escalate
if half the country decides to start
going and killing democrats
then you know i don't want to be a
victim
you know and like honestly i've never
thought about that happening
until until this election you know like
legitimate fear that you seriously think
that's a possibility
absolutely so this is seven six two by
five it makes for a combustible
atmosphere
as america braces for donald trump's
second impeachment trial
at a gun store across town no one wants
the ex-president
tried again it's a bad thing
it's a bad thing he's out of office
we're going to teach you for impeachment
is for to remove him from offense
he's already been removed he was whether
he believed whether the election was
stolen or not i'm not going to get in
there
but he's out of office he's gone now in
this part of america
it's like the election isn't over
because so many won't accept its result
since the election have been more than
60 attempts in the courts by donald
trump and his allies
to challenge his outcome and they've all
failed despite that in poll after poll
more than half of republicans say they
still believe the election was rigged
against him
for millions of americans there seems to
be a crisis of confidence
in their own democracy thousands of
votes have appeared from other
places to try and understand why we
caught up with mark hanger
grandfather and businessman and now
aggrieved trump supporter
despite all the evidence he insists the
wrong man is in the white house
little i think one that night donald
john trump
you convinced of that yes and that means
your democratic system
is broken me just cracked pretty bad
you're a successful educated businessman
you're not a conspiracy theorist
but you still think the election was
rigged even though there'd been i think
more than 60 attempts to challenge it in
the courts and
none of them have stood up in court yeah
you're right
there's such a hatred for donald trump
that i think that many many people said
no matter what it takes no matter what
it takes
good bad or indifferent we got to get
him out of there
pointing around this way here there are
millions like him living in an
alternative reality
despite joe biden's clear election
victory
as a second divisive impeachment battle
dominick waghorn sky news in west
virginia